[cheers and applause]
>> WELCOME TO THIS VERY SPECIAL
CHRISTMAS EVE MINI-SODE
OF @MIDNIGHT.
I AM YOUR HOST, CHRIS HARDWICK.
SO IN HONOR OF THE HOLIDAY,
MY NOM DE PLUME
IS NOW CHRIST HARDWICK.
BE SURE TO TWEET ME
YOUR ANGRY REPLIES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE.
TONIGHT'S PANEL CONSISTS
OF THREE MALL SANTAS.
HOW'S IT GOING, GUYS?
[cheers and applause]
>> I TOTALED MY PONTIAC SUNFIRE.
>> OH, SORRY.
>> CHRISTMAS
IS A HOLIDAY INVENTED
BY THE WHITE MAN
TO KEEP THE BLACK MAN DOWN.
>> YEAH.
>> MY WIFE LEFT ME FOR A
YOUNGER,
MORE FERTILE MAN.
>> YOU GUYS
ARE IN VERY POOR SHAPE.
BUT LET'S NOT DWELL ON THAT.
LET'S GET INTO TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
[cheers and applause]
NOW, SINCE IT IS
THE YULETIDE SEASON,
TONIGHT'S HOLIDAY-THEMED HASHTAG
IS RUIN A CHRISTMAS CAROL.
RUIN A CHRISTMAS CAROL.
EXAMPLES OF THIS MIGHT INCLUDE
"DICK THE HALLS"
OR "I'M DREAMING
OF A WHITES-ONLY CHRISTMAS."
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK STARTING NOW.
AND BEGIN.
YES.
>> "I SAW MOMMY
FISTING SANTA CLAUS."
>> PERFECT.
POINTS.
BRIAN.
>> "I SAW MOMMY
FELCHING SANTA CLAUS."
>> POINTS.
AISHA.
>> "DECK THE HALLS
WITH BOUGHS OF FECES."
>> POINTS.
OR WOULD THOSE COME
FROM THE BOWELS OF HOLLY?
>> INDEED.
>> YEAH, STEVE.
>> "O LITTLE TOWN
OF BETHLEHEM, PENNSYLVANIA,
IS ROCKED BY A MALL SHOOTING."
>> POINTS.
GOD DAMN IT.
YES, BRIAN.
>> "I SAW MOMMY
BLUMPKINING SANTA CLAUS."
>> SO HE MADE IT ALL THE WAY
INTO THE BATHROOM.
YEAH.
I MEAN, SANTA'S BEEN EATING
ALL THOSE COOKIES.
>> MOMMY'S KIND OF A WHORE.
>> POINTS.
YES, STEVE.
>> "BABY, IT'S COLD OUTSIDE
'CAUSE WE'RE HOMELESS."
>> YEAH, POINTS.
AISHA.
>> "IT CAME UPON A MIDNIGHT
CLEAR
AND MURDERED MY ENTIRE FAMILY
IN THEIR BEDS."
>> POINTS.
STEVE.
>> "SILENT NIGHT BECAUSE ZOMBIES
ARE ROAMING THE STREETS
AND THEY'RE ATTRACTED TO SOUND."
>> POINTS.
THAT'S TRUE.
LAST ONE. AISHA.
>> UH, "RUDOLPH
THE RED-NOSED REINDEER
HAS A DEVIATED SEPTUM
FROM TOO MUCH COCAINE."
>> POINTS.
YES, OF COURSE.
BUT THAT'S HOW HE'S ABLE
TO LEAD THE PACK.
IN TOTALING UP THE POINTS,
I SEE THAT IT'S A COMPLETE TIE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ACROSS THE BOARD.
A VERY SPECIAL HOLIDAY GIFT.
YOUR CHRISTMAS PRIZE
IS A RIDE HOME.
>> CAN YOU, UH, DROP ME OFF
AT THE MEN'S SHELTER?
OR THE WOMEN'S SHELTER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> UH, NO, I DON'T WANT YOU
TO SMELL UP MY JAGUAR.
I'M @NERDIST ON THE INSTAGRAMS
AND THE TWEETS.
AND A MERRY CHRISTMAS TO ALL
AND TO ALL A GOOD @MIDNIGHT.